welcome everyone and could you please
take a seat so we could start
[Music]
okay the dear laureates colleagues
friends students ladies and gentlemen
when we listen to music or look at the
world around us or smell the air when
the first snow is falling there are
molecules in our cells that move change
their shapes bind to each other imagine
if we could see all this and it became
possible through the work of this year's
laureates so the Nobel Prize for
chemistry 2017 has been awarded to
Jacques DeBusschere he work in Frank and
Richard Henderson for developing
cryo-electron microscopy for the high
resolution structure determination of
biomolecules in solution if this sounds
complicated on the next slide
cool microscopy captures life in atomic
detail this is what it is about the
electron microscope was invented almost
a hundred years ago it would take many
decades before the instrument could be
used to study biological molecules then
many more decades passed and during that
time we could only see molecules at
atomic at relatively low resolution as
seen on the left side we could see the
outer shapes or blobs of those caused
and that field was referred to as blue
Balaji but some people then in a
relatively short time the information
content in the pictures were was
increased by a factor of thousand and we
could see their atoms here of the
molecules and this is where we are today
about 25 years ago Richard Henderson
demonstrated for the first time that
cryo-electron microscopy could be used
to visualize biological objects at
atomic resolution already at that time
he predicted that the technique and this
is what he wrote in his article could
become a routine and quick method to be
used for obtaining these structures this
is where we are today and many of the
more recent improvements have also been
done by Richard but during the years we
have not only been able to harvest the
fruits of Richard's work he has also
generously shared the seeds with his
colleagues and co-workers so that they
could grow their own research
environments and directions and I think
that has been very important in the
field so now it's my privilege to
introduce the first speaker Richard
Anderson please
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you very much indeed Peter for
that kind introduction and of course
it's also a great honor to be selected
by the Nobel Committee for chemistry and
the Royal Swedish Academy to to share
with Jacques and Yocum
this year's 2017 Nobel Prize in
Chemistry but I wanted to begin by
saying that the three of us are really
representatives of what's now become
quite closely knit and well organized
filled with a phenomenal growth rate so
I'd like to start by showing the first
slide which is from the first three
dimensional electron microscopy annual
Gordon conference that was organized in
1985 by the two people in the yellow
circles nigel Anwen and watch ooh and so
they had the idea this field was going
to grow and inaugurated this meeting
which is now held every year and I think
you can see in the red circles that
Jacques Yocum and I are clustered around
being as close as possible to Nigel and
wah but there are other people in in the
and this is about a hundred people who
are where the field was starting there's
a few more who weren't at the meeting
but I particularly wanted to point out
because the group of Bob Glaser Ken
Taylor and Ken downing they were doing
low-temperature
electron microscopy cryo microscopy
before those of us who are here today so
they were early adopters of that idea
and then because I'm the first speaker I
wanted to show also a kind of overview
of so that you know what is electron cry
microscopy which we call cry wee M for
short and it comes in many different
flavors because once you have a good
electron cry microscope you can put all
sorts of different specimens into it and
this slide sort of summarizes a variety
of the things that have been studied and
have been quite
informative so on the left is a field of
view showing amorphous ice with
ribosomes embedded in it this is single
particles without symmetry and this is
from work that you will hear more about
from yoke and Frank and this was their
state of play in roughly the year 2000
from a review that Tim Baker and I wrote
so single particles without symmetry
single particles with symmetry this is
hepatitis B virus caused from Bettina
butchers work in 1997 this was the first
structure that went below nanometer
below 10 angstrom resolution and then
the third panel is helical arrangements
of biomolecules so this is the thin
filaments in muscle decorated with
subunits of myosin from the work of Ron
Milliken the blue is actin the green is
tropomyosin and the different colors
pink orange and yellow are the different
domains of the myosin that's involved in
muscle contractility this is relatively
low-resolution all of these are fairly
low-resolution but on the right is the
2d crystals that I'll talk about it at
the beginning of my own part of the talk
this was the second high-resolution
structure determined by cryo a.m. by
Verner cool Brandt and with
collaboration with fujiyoshi in Japan in
in 1994 and shows a 2d crystal at higher
resolution because the 2d crystals were
easier to start with which is how I'll
start so that is a range of specimens
giving you a kind of overview the
structures here are about six times
bigger magnification than the images at
the top but you can see and it's this is
so this is much easier to understand
than the gravitational waves and the
black holes you just take images of the
molecules you can see them and then in
the computer you calculate the structure
so you know anyone can do this kind of
work so then I want to jump forward and
this is this year's Gordon conference so
this is now 32 years later it's a it's a
bigger group more highly selected
you see some of the faces Bob Glaser and
and Yocum myself but I've outlined in
yellow some of the people who more
recently have made very important
contributions in terms of developing all
the computer programs it has make it so
easy and so popular amongst newcomers
who don't know so much about it so Fred
Singh was one of the original maximum
maximum likelihood sure share as an
equal Grigory F Marion van heel who'd
worked with Yocum at one point and and
correct so from Spain and then to other
people in the pale blue Bridget Carey
Kerr and Helen Sabol who in the USA and
in Europe have been very important in
running courses and educating people
although they also did individual work
in the past so that gives you a little
bit of an overview of the community and
how the closely knit sort of brother and
sisterhood of cryo-em has adopted its
own sort of culture and identity and
that's very important and so we are only
the tip of the iceberg if you like in
this crime area and then to give you an
idea of where we are now this is the
growth in the deep positions of
high-resolution atomic coordinates in
the protein databank which traditionally
had only coordinates deposited from
x-ray crystallography and nuclear
magnetic resonance spectroscopy and you
see back in in the 1990s and so on there
were invisible numbers of structures but
in the last five years has been a great
growth and it looks like this year we
learned that with about 700 new
structures deposited in this protein
databank
more maps and and we then have a we have
the Gordon conferences there's a 3d en
mailing list which didn't exist until
1995 started by Ross Smith but when that
first Gordon conference started we were
probably about a hundred or 150 people
now there are 3,000 people who subscribe
to that mailing list so that gives you
an idea of the field and the importance
of the community so now I just like to
I'm going to do three things in this
talk so tell you how I got involved
in being converted by meeting Nigel and
went from an x-ray crystallographer to
an electron microscopy enthusiast and
then how we work together to get a low
resolution structure of a membrane
protein bacteria Dobson then a high
resolution structure and then how our
own efforts switched from being electron
crystallography into single particle e/m
and which has been the methodology
that's made the method really popular so
going back now to about in my case 1971
or 72 I heard a talk by water stickiness
in San Francisco this is the first time
he talked about it he had in a bacterium
halo bacteria these membrane areas the
his creations these are little
two-dimensional crystals one molecule
thick and with backing and support from
Don angleman and Tom Stites at Yale we
phoned up zucchinis and got some samples
of these bacteria grew the map and then
purified these membranes and each one of
these is a little single crystal maybe a
hundred molecules or two hundred across
so 20 or 30,000 of these identical
protein molecules in this 2d crystal and
my original plan had been to dissolve
them in detergent make 3d crystals or
analyze the 2d pattern this is an x-ray
powder pattern from stacks pellets of
those same membranes that you saw in
single sheets and so there are lots of
spots you can see they go out this would
be the one the first spot second third
and so on and this is about seven
angstrom resolution they're all very
strong but you can see them all going
out and you can index them right oh
right the way out to three or four
angstrom resolution so that showed that
these 2d crystals were really highly
ordered and very suitable for structural
analysis and at that point I had the
great good fortune to meet Nigel Unwin
who had been giving a talk about
electron microscopy using negative stain
but in that top it was clear he was
thinking about
how the images would also contain inside
the stain the images of the proteins
that were being encased in it so we work
together for two or three years doing on
these little patches that would be one
of these crystals electron diffraction
and these spots are the diffraction
spots from the lattice and molecules in
the crystal and images that could then
be analyzed either in the computer or by
optical diffraction to give you the
amplitudes and phases of the furry
components that describe the
distribution in the matter in the
crystals and when we we only saw the
spots and we had numbers we wrote them a
sheet of paper and then to our great
delight when we submitted these averages
and phases to the computer and then went
down to the big computer in Cambridge
University we got this map which was
surprisingly informative and very
beautiful we thought the the plotter
which was the only accurate plotter in
all of Cambridge at a time had three
color pens the red green and the blue so
the red green and the black and it
showed in projection three of these
protein molecules with big Peaks 10
angstroms apart and and we'd already
suspected from the x-ray pattern that
there were alpha helixes this is the
Pauling quarry alpha helix from the
model building that needed in the 1950s
and which had been discovered in
myoglobin and hemoglobin but here we now
have these alpha helix YZ pointing
towards us in a top view of the
membranes so then we continued tilted
the specimens and went into 3d got these
3d maps that are plotted on sheets of
perspex with hand drawn the the computer
plotter couldn't do floating on per spec
sheet so these had to be hand drawn from
computer plots and then looking at it
sideways we built this balsa wood model
in 3d which showed that not only the
four after Gila C's that could be seen
and on in the projection but with slight
tilts there were seven transmembrane
helix season this was the first real
strong and hard knowledge about the
structure of membrane proteins 1975 we
were at that point stop in terms of
knowing that the crystals were better
ordered but not knowing how to to
proceed and then we tried various things
but in the interim Hartmann would Mikkel
who had been also working on bhakti
Robson managed to crystallize another
membrane protein so in the end the first
high-resolution membrane structure was
the reaction centers that Heartland
Michael and his colleagues from artist
Reed were given the chemistry Nobel
Prize in 1988 which was before we
managed to do any better with this so
then we went on and tried to go from
seven angstroms to a higher resolution
where you could see the chemistry the
amino acids in the side chains and that
needed a couple of things it needed
higher resolution electron diffraction
patterns and all the work I've shown you
up to now was done with specimens at
room temperature where the water that
normally surrounds the the the protein
that the membranes had been replaced by
a sugar solution by glucose but now we
had cold stages in Cambridge that we
could take electron diffraction patterns
on film initially and this one was later
with the development of electronic
detectors but our microscopes in
Cambridge were not capable of doing
high-resolution imaging of cryo
specimens and and what encouraged us was
this paper from watch you the same
person who chaired the very first
program of 3d M Gordon conference he had
worked with Fritz Sam Lynn in Berlin who
had a very high-performance prototype
microscope that had been made by the
siemens company liquid helium lens a
liquid helium stage and he took pictures
of this two dimensional three slightly
thin 3d crystal of pro toxin a structure
we still don't know to this day but he
showed images of crystals with
diffraction spots from the
bridges that went beyond 4 angstroms
23.9 just the resolution that we were
looking for so this and the existence of
the electron diffraction patterns with
cryo convinced us that we should make a
major effort then to get into high
resolution electron cryo microscopy with
the idea of determining the stretch of
this membrane protein but on in doing
that we did try other things for many
years and so on this slide in red is
what worked and in these other three
panels are other ideas that we tried so
tom Seska David a guard and Joyce
Baldwin tried this was our idea to bring
the methods of x-ray crystallography
into electron crystallography but they
weren't they just weren't powerful
enough the heavy atoms don't scatter as
much any electrons and so on this was
the idea of using heavy atom derivatives
we found the heavy atoms but the phasing
power was not enough we tried model
building we knew where the HeLa C's were
so in principle you could search for the
location wasn't perfect after we tried
molecular replacement with more than one
crystal form it worked slightly but
again not powerful enough what worked in
the end was to take images just like you
saw for Crowe toxin from watches work in
Berlin and then also we began actually
with a one-week trip to Jacques Dubois
Shay's lab who was an EMBL at that time
he'll tell you about this later and
Zhang de Paul worked for a week on a
really very difficult to use microscope
I think which they dismantled after that
we did get one image the very first
high-resolution image which then gave us
further encouragement and then visiting
Burton's 1984-1985 following in watch
his footsteps we went to to Berlin
Fritz Emmaline eric Becklund worked for
many years 5 or 6 years taking images
making the microscope better and then in
parallel
Bob Glaser who had been visiting us
persuaded Ken downing also to take
pictures so in the end we had
contributions from three different labs
travel and we also tried in Cambridge
but we never got image as good as these
these were all prototype
noncommercial not available and of
course after it worked we then try to
put pressure on the microscope
manufacturers to develop the commercial
versions which mean it is what we now
use in parallel with the practical
problem of getting really good high
resolution images there were a number of
technical things that I won't go into
but particularly finding out that beam
tilt was one of the critical problems
that we hadn't realized and I'll figure
out a way in tilted specimens to correct
for the different height the different D
focus but after doing that we ended up
with improved maps so eventually from
1975 to 1950 years worth of various
problems I don't think it cost nearly so
much as the gravity wave project but we
went from this is the same map I showed
you with the balsa wood model 7 angstrom
resolution in 1975 slightly better by
molecular replacement these features
turned out to be real although we
weren't sure at the time and then the
first 50 images gave us a map with more
better resolve features and eventually
with about 70 we got a map where you can
see key features sticking out from the
alpha helixes and at higher
magnification they looked like this and
when we then tried to interpret that map
using the amino acid sequence from
ovchinnikov and caranas lab which by
then had been determined by biochemistry
we found that you could interpret the
map and see phenylalanine tyrosine
tryptophan and other tyrosine and then
the retinal the color of the membranes
they were purple we could see all of
these structures and built a complete
atomic model of the battery ops and that
was about 1990 and it was the first
high-resolution structure where you
could use electron microscopy to
determine the structures so then we went
on and did other work in the early 1990s
nickel grigoriev refined the structure
Sri Ram came we did lots of kinetic
strapping intermediates and so on but at
that time I also got involved in a
review for an x-ray microscope and ended
up writing a review comparing the
radiation damage from neutrons x-rays
electrons and I then became completely
convinced that the e/m method was
definitely the way to go and had an
enormous untapped potential so we
switched our effort from working on
electron crystallography with crystals
you still have to make crystals whether
it's in 2d or 3d to working on single
particles and and trying to assist the
method in going from the relatively low
resolution to try to go to a higher
resolution and of course in this respect
Jacques will tell you about this in due
course Jaques group at the MBL had been
exploring the behavior of water when he
froze it and they had a variety of of
gravity-driven or elastic band driven
freezing apparatuses and I thought I'd
just since I'm speaking first I should
give you a little outline of it and this
is the the cryo e/m grid preparation
method that mark Adrien Alastair
McDowell who's here and Jacques
developed in the early 1980s the idea is
you take grids that have got wholly
carbon films on it this says wholly
carbon film you you take them one at a
time in a pair of forceps you apply a
drop of your solution with your protein
of choice or you arrive in some or
whatever you blot it on a piece of
filter paper and then you plunge it one
or two meters per second into liquid
ethane which was allister's idea
occasionally when we were working on
bacteria we also flashed it with light
but when you did that you get images
beautiful images where you see the
amorphous ice this was a specimen that
Richard param gave us Peter Rosenthal
made the specimen veena of Kumar took
this image quite recently with the new
detectors you can see the particles you
could see their orientation it's clear
without doing any further computation
that it's really powerful and then this
is the very first hepatitis V virus core
work that came from Tony Grider's group
done by Bettina butcher and Nikolay
kiselev had brought from Riga in Latvia
a specimen early on in 1994 and using
older microscopes not such bright
sources not very Korean they got a first
30 angstrom resolution cryo-em structure
in 1994 and then we bought a
a higher voltage field emission gun
brighter source microscope which Bettina
used with specimens that Sam when had
made in Tony's computer program and they
got this then first structure from
single-party work to go below 10
angstroms we called it sub nanometer
structure and of course now we're now 20
years further on this is a recent paper
published from Hong Joos group at UCLA
higher voltage brighter microscope much
more stable but still all of these are
pictures taken on film and they got a
3.5 angstrom resolution structure you
can see these are after he received a
bundle of four alpha helixes you can see
the side chains and so on so the
microscopes due to pressure from the
academic researchers but response by the
microscope countries produce much better
data so then the thing that's kicked the
field off in the last few years these
new detectors came in previously we were
using film there are three companies
that now make detectors there now better
than this they're now up here this would
be a perfect detector at the top using
these detectors I'm going to show you
just two structures one of them is
beating like societies which I think was
the structure that Peter had in his
introductory slide this is a half a mega
Dalton structure it's the lack see the
very first operon discovered in the
early stages of understanding gene
expression and we had adopted this in
1997 when Sriram Subramanian and
Jacqueline mills were there learning and
deciding to get into cryo a.m. and this
was the first we didn't believe this
structure in 2005 low resolution this is
the first time we believed it this was
done on film and we hadn't by then we
had new analytical methods till pairs
and so on that proved that this was
correct but as soon as the new detectors
came in here we had higher resolution
and then with new programs such as rely
on from Shores Charon the same data gave
us much higher resolution you could
resolve then the strands of the
polypeptide in the beta sheets and then
Sriram who had by then an independent
group at NIH worked much harder on this
turn the magnet
collected better data and has now a 2.2
angstrom data structure and I've
believed now this is now better than 2
angstroms from subsequent work and then
a second one I wanted to show you is
mitochondrial complex one which again
nickel grigoriev had worked on back in
the late 1990s with film and got to
about 20 angstrom resolution recently
Judy Hearst from another MRC unit
brought a sample across and vinoth Kumar
started to take it this is one of his
pictures this is a one mega Dalton
complex with 45 different proteins in it
and it has no symmetry you can see it
has also two different views when you
record images and process them you get a
map like this in 3d contour at one level
or at a higher level and you can see the
eight iron sulfur complexes where
electrons are fed in from nadh come down
into the membrane into quinone and
involved in proton transport and then in
the membrane there are 76 transmembrane
helix sees this is about 5 angstrom
resolution so you rather similar to the
bacteria adopts an early map at room
temperature so you can see the general
structure of the of the protein but not
the detailed chemistry for which you
need higher resolution and then at a at
a lower con to a level still you see the
band of lipid and detergent that sounds
surrounds this membrane and the protein
but V North JPEG Jew who had prepared
the protein in Judy hers group went on
and improved it until they eventually
got a model with all 45 polypeptides
identified and largely built although
there were some poly alanine giving you
a complete atomic model for the
structure and in blue in the background
are the core subunits that a bacterial
homologue of this mitochondrial membrane
protein involved in proton transport
coupling to oxidative phosphorylation
the blue is a bacterial homologue that
leo satin offs group had determined
earlier by x-ray crystallography so
that's a kind of complete summary from
staged bacterial Dopson to higher
resolution and then switching the the
approach if cry we am into the single
particle area I just want to finish that
with one slide and this is from recent
work that in the last year Chris Russo
and I have been doing and Chris's is in
the audience here and the idea is where
are we now
so we are now and so what this is this
tells you the amount of information in
images that you get with the new
microscopes and the new detectors and
this is the exposure that you're giving
it five electrons per square angstrom
then 10 and 15 and radiation damage
eventually kills the structure you're
turning it into a cinder a carbon
carbonaceous fragment of what was once a
beautiful protein so this is what we
what we observe when we analyze the data
but what we know we ought to observe if
all the remaining problems that exist
which are not nearly so profound as the
problems in getting gravitational waves
to go forward the red is where we are
hoping to be and then there are a number
of factors that explain we think why we
don't do as well as we should in theory
and the idea now for the next year or
two is to try to address all of these
problems but the main one being in this
blue area is dementia specimen motion
from the radiation damage or from
releasing stresses that are is a result
of the freezing in the first place and
then when we do that we think you'll be
able to do all the things I showed you
lots more
more than a thousand structures per year
and so on and it will be less work and
more high-resolution as on so with that
I wanted to finish by saying that of
course quite a number of people have
been involved and I've worked with them
personally but the main one at the
beginning which which basically
converted me from an x-ray
crystallographer to an electron
microscopist and I think there was a
slight action and reaction because after
we had worked together on bacterial
officer Nigel also changed still doing
electron microscopy but doing it on
membrane proteins as well so it was a
important branching of our
potential career paths for both of us
and then we had this 15-year gap where
we had to work on a lot of different
methods and in Cambridge
Joyce Baldwin Tom Seska and David a
guard were the ones who were pushing it
but Bob Glaser and Ken downing were
important to taking pictures but
particularly Fitz and semolina and Eric
worked very hard for many years and then
we had this one week with with Jacques
and Zhang Nepal in the early stages that
so that was the high resolution group
and then recently we've been involved in
a lot of the attempts to improve the
methodology through detective
development and microscope technical
developments and these are the people
huazi Greg and Xiao Jie who is here from
Cambridge and the two people from
Rutherford Appleton science technology
facility Carson near Oxford who have
spent 15 years or so developing one of
the three types of detector that you can
now buy from the market and then more
recently when we switched into single
particle work I mentioned most of these
in John Rubinstein who were on one of
the different type of ATPase rotary
motor and Peter Rosenthal who prepared
one of the specimens that I showed you
before and then the early the most
recent work in all of the biological
structures like complex one came from V
North Kumar who is now just opened a new
crime facility in Bangalore in India and
then finally in the last year Chris ruse
and I have been trying to address and
solve the remaining problems for the
future and then I should just finish by
saying that most of the work obviously
the people from other labs were funded
by other agencies but most of this was
funded by the Medical Research Council
which has always had since the time of
brutes and Kendrew a clear mandate to do
long term support for projects that take
longer than typical project state so
with that thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
we are composed of 70% water ourselves
all the molecules inside are surrounded
by water as pointed out by Jacques de
Lucia in 1995 he wrote that during the
first 50 years after the invention of
the electron microscope the most
abundant constituent of living things
water had been excluded from studies
using the electron microscope Jacques
develop a preparation method that solve
this problem it is based on cooling
water so rapidly that the water
molecules are trapped in a disordered
state which is called glass or liquefied
this phenomenon was considered to be
impossible and we will soon learn how
the impossible became reality but the
road was slippery as we will here but on
on this ride Jacques has also looked
beyond the molecules and unfortunately
my French is not that good but from what
I understand by reading the texts that
rock has presented that he he writes
with a warm and open heart of a humanist
on topics on opinions on topics covering
problems of our society politics and of
course science of which we will hear
more about in his presentation I now
introduce it's a great privilege to
introduce dr. Boucher 70% water 100%
warm curiosity
[Music]
[Applause]
well in this very special moment I am
overwhelmed with gratitude gratitude for
my parents for my family my friends my
collaborators for the Royal Swedish
Academy of Science and the Noble
Foundation this can be well understood
but I want to address special thanks to
those two person
it was kallenberg was my what so what is
called dr. fat he brought me in to
science it taught me to be a scientist
and he explained to me that science is
something that should happen in a
society
Sir John Kendrew was the first general
director of embl and he gave me this
tremendous chance to work on this quite
strange project of dealing with water in
the electron microscope so why cryo-em
because as you said we are made out we
are bags of water and bags of water made
of billions of cells which are each one
bags of water and if you remove the
water everything floating in the cellar
in the body will will condensate will
aggregate and if you are good in
arranging the specimen when removing the
water you will get fine aggregates if
you are not so good you get coarse
aggregates but aggregates you get
because fish doesn't fly so even a very
tough object like this default
bacteriophage when you dry
them on a supporting film they are in a
very bad shape
oh so people develop remarkable method
to preserve the specimen though the
water is removed one eye one
certainly one fine method is to dry the
specimen in a solution of heavy salt and
the more the water go the more the soul
concentrated at the end you have only
the particle with salt around it heavy
salt heavy metal salt which hold the
structure more or less correctly
another possibility is freeze right you
freeze the specimen and instead of
reivew removing the water from the
liquid you remove it from the solid and
it has great advantage but if you look
carefully the head of this poor
bacteriophage doesn't look very healthy
so at that time my hero is still my hero
was is Nigel hanwen and we were working
in very parallel direction each one
trying all kind of trick to have a
better preservation of the specimen he
had a funny idea
he thought instead of drying the
specimen in in heavy metal salt heavy
metal salt is not healthy he dry them in
sugar because sugar is much better for
the material and he joined his force as
you know with this guy with with fish
shark and together they got this
remarkable result 99 with this then 90
degrees and 75 what am marking history
another person was very important a
boost I moved too much
yes you have already heard all that but
Glaser perhaps you should stay here bug
laser during my PhD and so I did a lot
of work just following his steps but the
the most impressive message I got off
from him was this photograph and this is
this is these are bacteria quite broken
with all kind of sub structure of the
bacteria but what is special we were
working with this kind of thing with all
all our trick for trying to better
preserve the specimen in sugar or in any
other thing but here he had it in ice in
frozen ice we see the marks of the ice
but it's beautifully preserved and
having seen that I thought oh this is
than anything I've seen before and this
is the future so two years later I was
invited to be group group leader at Yale
by John Kendrew with this project how to
deal with water in cryo electron
microscopes so there is a problem though
frozen water is ice and ice is not
liquid water and it's as bad for a
biological specimen to be in ice than to
be without water but we were trying all
kind of tricks this is our high
technology device and it goes like that
we will try many many things but this is
one of the things we had a nebulizer
coming from the right here
high pressure nebulized throwing a
stream of micro droplets of water of any
kind of suspension and going through
this
all slit here the slit and here you have
a tweezer and at the top of the tweezer
you have one of this supporting film
this grid that you use a specimen order
in the electron microscope and while the
stream of droplets is going you let this
fall down in the liquid nitrogen and we
got like that things like that a nice
droplet of ice and this is
characteristic ice now we have the
MacDowell I can't see him but he is here
thought I will do better and it put here
and here just in the liquid nitrogen
here a very small beaker with very
condensed liquid ethane and instead of
letting the specimen fall down in liquid
nitrogen in let it fall down in liquid
ethane and so he went to the microscope
look at the object in the electron
microscope and called me hey if there is
something here and this was what this is
what we see and this is Beatrice then
this is not crystallized so we didn't
knew what this was the first idea is its
liquid if they iterate it's Ethan which
has been condensed here
no it can't be the temperature that
temperature Ethan should have been gone
should they have evaporated so we
thought ok we will let it evaporate and
we will see what it is so we turn off
the cooling of the specimen holder and
we'll let it warm I do not remember how
long it last part of an hour warm slowly
and when we came at minus 135 certainly
but in really teller rally in one second
the drop transform into a milky crystal
that we recognize it
immediately this was Cuba guys you
because is a different form of ice quite
conventional we had it studied before in
detail in our previous experiment and
electron diffraction told confirm it
it's ice so if you have a bit if you
have a vigorous droplet which turn into
ice you know that you had bitterest
water ha so what do you do with that ah
this is Alistair McDowell vitrification
man great this was the first haha I
remember I said at that moment oh we
have something great Juli and the
trouble with vitrification with which
which water is that vitrification should
be impossible what are this mean yes I
will not go into the detail I will just
mention the founder of cryobiology
father basil Riya who work is you is a
Catholic priest in a very severe
Catholic congregation and he worked for
40 years in trying to produce suspended
life this means immobilizing life or in
order to obtain typically for breeding
typically any make a lot of money with
this not for him but for his
congregation and and it was working with
very good people and those people with
him demonstrate that vitrification was
impossible at the end for thermodynamic
already complicated reason that I am NOT
going to explain in detail so I want to
speak about this man for another reason
he was born in savea's in valise
Switzerland and I start school just very
close to him in a place which is would
be here in the small village just on the
other side of the valley
here and at present we have still a nice
chalet here nice Mountain huh
here and for those who like love
mountains this is the so called vanilla
this is the blush beautiful mountain
okay so so our beautification we send it
for publication and we got rapidly this
answer no you
it was reject that you can't spend
nature and they were wrong they were all
wrong for two reasons the first one if
that while they were rejecting our paper
they had on the print press the paper by
burglar and Meyer who was who was
proving that obtaining complete
vitrification in pure liquid water and
dilute aqueous solution that means they
made the discovered the discovery that
nitrification is possible and then it
was they were doubly wrong because
vitrification is very easy that's and
with our method
it was reproducible rapid and no problem
so so what do you do with that first
conclusion Mitra SWAT is not simple it's
not just liquid water immobilized in the
same shape no no it's something else but
doesn't matter it's it works so well for
cryo-electron microscopy that we don't
dare to go into the detail though when
we will go into the detail we will
certainly understand very important
things about water that we yet don't
know and perhaps it will be important
for biology also ii haha came can be
explained like that we work with these
grids and on the grids we have a thin
thin film and we spread the specimen on
the grid but this is difficult
because water has high surface tension
and what won't what
want water is to form a sphere minimize
the surface and trying to maximize the
surface on a grid is just technically
difficult you have to arrange the
surface so that too high number just
come
equally in negative one to Eve and the
other it's a complicated process and my
collaborator Macario at that time he
died unfortunately very badly after they
were stupidly after his retirement and
this is a very remarkable person he is
very stubborn extraordinary cultivated
and it has an enormous culture and very
stubborn and it was not at all
interested in spreading the water water
on the grid so he wanted to have no
support and he was worried he was
working trying to get the specimen on
the holes of the grid without support I
was quite opposed to that because there
is no chance but because I knew the
physics but he did he got that and it
turns out that it was not so it was
quite easy very easy in fact and this is
the typical example on whole of the on
the whole of the grid which is 20
micrometer broad he get this dance from
my sense of micrometer thick layer
spreading over the whole grid so the
film is 200 times thinner than broad
technically in term of energy it's quite
strange but it works well later we
understood why there aren't interesting
energy and thermodynamic reason which
explain all that but at that time we
were not aware of that so the method and
now comes the most difficult part of the
Samina well I hope this is how it should
go
so you have a grid a grid on the tweezer
have a beaker with liquid nitrogen you
have liquid ethane and dr. o
we try again before you came with the
blotting paper as you explained in one
second to grid the liquid disappear in
the oh yes what water disappear goes in
the blotting paper and but the last
tenth of a micron takes another second
to go away and you have time to let the
grid fall down and get the sample get me
through fight this was 89 1984 this was
rapidly published whether the the
general director of embl was a new
person and he was not leather philipson
and he was not very happy with those
physicists working with water and but so
we worked with his bath virus the
adenovirus and when he got this nice
photograph he was convinced and we
became the best friend in the world and
and so was it and you notice but of
course you have heard more and you will
heard hear much more from drug him in a
moment when you have the particle
floating in water in all with all
orientation you can make 3d
reconstruction and so we had this 1986
this model of virus at 35 angstrom
resolution 35 action resolution that's
that was that and so came the beautiful
word blob all orgy blob barrage yes this
is blah blah
and then a lot of people continue to
work we're working before we were also
working but those those you understand
were very well what are they more
important than the other I guess yes
but they were playing to your father and
so we had 30 years we had ten times
better resolution 10 times better
resolution this means thousand thousand
times smaller volume this means thousand
times more density of information and
this is not a small smaller achievement
and and three point five thirty five to
three point five both these are just
number but three point five mean seeing
atoms and when you see atoms then you
are a chemist and and therefore you have
from cryo-em all the power of chemistry
which means that you see how filaments
aggregates together how you the brain
becomes senile perhaps because of that
you say perhaps you will see how you
will find a drug which will prevent them
to aggregates perhaps now I come to the
onion to my reading now you perhaps we
will understand how to do medicine with
that there are plenty of people were
interested with results there and
science will continue it will take time
to explore the brain we may understand
understand how we think perhaps
conscience will emerge this is knowledge
without limit its
yes but knowledge has its consequence
knowledge makes what what our lives are
when the year we discovered we we
publish the 15 vitrification method I
got my first personal computer now now
billion 1 billion of people are our city
is sitting in front of a computer screen
for most part of their day and
communication between people is
fundamentally change my the father of my
grandfather was living in scarcity he
was never sure to be able to bring home
the minimum required for decent life for
his family we are now submerge with
access and the world climate is getting
robbed and the glacier just above our
mountain hut is collapsing we have a
problem
Shas
sarkozy on sneaker wind alarm this is
not very new roughly 500 years ago but
now it's getting very actual and very
urgent well yes and oh sorry the region
what can we do it's very urgent what can
we do one thing is certain we scientist
must come out of our ivory tower and be
involved in the Society for which we
produce knowledge that knowledge can it
can be equally can have equally good or
bad concept
and we must become more aware and
responsible for these this is the reason
why more than 20 years ago we introduced
in our university a compulsory
curriculum biology and society because
we want our students to be as good
citizen as they are good biologist this
is good but this is not enough how can
we be as good in using our knowledge for
the well-being of all as we are in
producing it I don't know you see we are
used to speak freely but this part is in
some ways too important to be said like
that therefore I want to write it - - I
wrote it down and it's make it very
complicated yes I don't know but we must
fight for our most precious good namely
we must protect and fight for the common
the for knowledge knowledge is our
common good and which must make out of
it the best for the well-being of all
now if a future generation imagine even
imagine imagine if it's easy if you try
imagine for example we think about else
imagine that we take the w-h-o the World
Health Organization or the organism of
the you know and imagine we and we we
give to this organism all the knowledge
about health and about medicine about
how to help people have and we and we
give this organism the right and the
power to deal to do the best with this
common knowledge of course we will give
those who produce the knowledge the
right where a war reward for the effort
it would not be hard to do
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You versa for leaving us with
these important souls electron
microscopy pictures of Biola male
biological molecules in water have very
low contrast in 1975 yucking Frank
realized that the challenge in using
electron microscopy for studies of
unstained biological molecules he wrote
there is the assignment of features that
are only faintly visible on noisy
background he solved the problem then he
spent more than 10 years on developing
methods to calculate three-dimensional
structures from these faint molecular
shadows we will hear more about this in
his lecture but perhaps what you know
less about is that yuck him is also
published author of poems and short
stories and he is a former president of
the Hudson Valley Writers Guild who
meets to discuss poetry and fiction and
as a colleague of your team recently
described your team's contributions he
has been exploring the intricacies of
the human heart with the same keen
insight and perception that he brings to
his scientific work we are now looking
forward to hear more many more details
of this scientific work it is my
privilege to introduce in three
dimensions that high resolution you work
in Frank
[Applause]
[Music]
members of the Academy distinguished
guests ladies and gentlemen allow me do
you speak about science rather than live
we open heard
it's an enormous honor to be selected as
one of this year's Nobel laureates in
chemistry I would like to thank the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences for
bestowing the Nobel Prize on me along
with my co laureates Richard Henderson
and dr. Boucher the thought of being
considered a peer of Ernest Rutherford
Marie Curie
and Linus Pauling is truly daunting I
developed an interest in electron
microscopy and when I worked with
against Hinda on loops
I developed an interest in electron
microscopy now who worked with Ernst
kinder on my master thesis and physics
at the University of Munich my thesis
had something to do with Beck scattering
of electrons in 1943 working with the
electron microscope he had studied
butterfly wings which as he realized
gain their brilliant colors from
interference of light on gratings formed
by tiny scales arranged in a regular
order I signed on II to a graduate
project with Walter hopper at the Max
Planck Institute in Munich an x-ray
crystallographer who had developed an
interest in electron microscopy as a
means to study biomolecules he viewed
the electron microscope as just the
diffractometer that unlike the one
employed an x-ray crystallography could
record not just amplitudes of diffracted
electrons but their faces as well this
was just a fancy way of saying electron
microscopes were able to form images for
the beginning years from 1930s to the
1950s the contributions of
from microscopy to biology were confined
mainly to the investigation of tissue
serious forays into a quantitative
visualization of molecular structure did
not start until the 1960s and were
concentrated in three groups aaron klug
at the lap of molecular biology the MRC
and Cambridge my mentor Walter hopper at
the Max Planck Institute in Munich and
Edward kallenberger as you heard at the
beer central in Basel now unless
symmetries are present the
three-dimensional reconstruction of an
object requires the combination of its
projections from a wide angular range
first pioneering achievements in
molecular structure in molecular
structure research with the electron
microscope with a three-dimensional
reconstruction of the barrack of
bacteriophage tail with helical symmetry
in 1968 by the ricean Kruk and the first
reconstruction of an icosahedral virus
in 1970 by tony Crowder in the same lab
at that time biological molecules could
not be imaged in a close to native state
negative staining which amounts to
embedding the molecule in the layer of
heavy metal salt was the only means
available to produce contrast on the
other hand biological molecules are
quite fragile and it was known that
maintenance of the integrity would
require a fully hydrated environment
when I started my work as a graduate
student of under the water hopper I was
exposed to discussions in small
workshops in the thurible Alps
co-organized by Walter hopper and Max
Perutz in Alba and once in here check
these were the first meetings that
brought together protein and
crystallographers and people working in
electron microscopy the many problems
faced in attempting to image biological
molecules
the electron microscope where discussed
at a workshop in he organized by edward
carnby and guys in the swiss alps in
1973 the state of the art at the time
was reflected in the title of a
proceedings paper since high resolution
was equated with any results better than
30 angstroms her amount at the meeting
was the search for a method that would
keep the molecule fully hydrated while
exposed to the electron beam following
pioneering studies by Pope Glazer in
1971 just at the time I visited his lab
as a Harkness fellow radiation damage
was recognized as a major obstacle in
the strife toward higher resolution
averaging of a large number of repeats
of a structure exposed to very low dose
was seen as a general solution to this
problem thus this meeting set the stage
for a groundbreaking study by Richard
Henderson a nodule on wind that you've
already heard about in 1975 the
reconstruction of parabolic period opsin
from the purple meander a mean of
halibut are embedded in glucose under
quasi native conditions the confluence
of novel approaches to sample
preparation data collection at extremely
low electron dose and merging a tilt
series of these noisy images made this
work a towering achievement the time
after that was marked by general
excitement in the community and many
attempts to use the same or similar
methods in a study of other proteins
amenable to a two-dimensional
crystallization
however the intrinsically low contrast
between proteins and glucose made these
attempts difficult and embedment and
eyes remained the agreed general goal at
the time most researchers in the field
that was to be called structural biology
were united in the belief that serious
structure determination required highly
ordered samples such as 2d crystals here
little fibers or viruses with high
symmetry
attempts to extract structural
information from freestanding single a
symmetric molecules were not taken
seriously one such alternative approach
pursued by Walter hopper he was to tilt
the am grid - which isolated molecules
were attached in the multiple angles
while collecting projections from which
the molecules could be reconstructed
while the angles are exactly known in
Hoppus tomographic approached the
accumulation of radiation damage over
multiple exposures to more than a
thousand electrons per angstrom square
at the time rendered the end result
essentially meaningless the other
approach was the one I formulated in a
concept paper in 1975 which I will
elaborate in the following so this
approach takes advantage of the fact
that in biological molecules purified
from cell extract and suspended in
solution typically exist in thousands or
even millions of copies that is separate
realizations of the same structure hence
if agreed to which such a sample has
been applied it put into the electron
microscope a large number of projection
image of the same molecules lying in
random orientations are encountered the
important point is that instead of
collecting multiple images from one
molecule by tilting it in the electron
microscope one merely has to take a
snapshot of multiple copies of that
molecule with a very small radiation
dose the advantage in the latter case is
of course that the 3d image obtained
relates to a molecule that has seen only
one single low exposure and has remained
practically and damaged the term
determines single particle averaging and
single party reconstruction which were
later coined refer to the fact that the
molecules in the sample are freestanding
and not attached to one another as in
the crystal
so at this point it is important to
reiterate that no symmetries are assumed
in this approach rather the idea was
that entirely a symmetric molecules
could be reconstructed in this way
symmetries obviously simplify the
problem as in that case the image
contains multiple projections of the
repeating unit in different known
orientations allowing data from
different molecules to be readily merged
now simple as the concept sounds the
realization of simple particular
construction required several problems
to be solved all in the area of image
processing first is it feasible at all
to align nauseum molecule images with
one another with sufficient accuracy
second how do we obtain how do we
estimate the resolution of a
reconstruction obtained by combining all
images third how do we sort molecule
images by appearance related to view
angle and confirmation fourth how do we
find the viewing angles of projections
our posterior fifth how do we
reconstruct molecules peeler molecule
from projections at randomly spaced new
angles so it was in the nature of these
problems and their novelty that progress
was slow and piecewise one step at a
time during the work on my PhD thesis
which was 1968 through 1971 explored the
use of cross correlation function for
aligning electron micrographs I
discovered there two successive images
of the same area of carbon could be
aligned with a position of better than 3
angstroms actually the process of 2d
alignment is a bit more complicated
since molecules picked from the
micrograph differ both in shift and
rotation the solution I found to
determine both relative rotation angles
and shifts simultaneously makes use of
the fact that the autocorrelation
function
of a molecule is a shift invariant it
does not depend on its position within
the image frame then working with Bourne
Sexton at the old Cavendish lab in the
group headed by Vernon crosslet I was
able to show that alignment by a cross
correlation would be accurate enough for
the purpose of aligning noisy images of
single molecules if the dose exceeded a
certain level which depended on the
molecule size and contrast against the
background using the ribosome as an
example it became clear from the formula
we obtained that single particle
approach to structural research was
indeed feasible for molecules of
sufficient size my appointment in 1975 a
senior research scientist at the
division of labs and research later
named Portsmouth Sunday and Albany
offered me the opportunity to explore
the idea with the help of samples
provided by collaborators I was able to
demonstrate the feasibility of obtaining
two-dimensional averages showing
enhanced features of molecules with
images of glutamine synthetase as a dual
colony receptor and 40s ribosomal
subunits from HeLa cells among these the
40s subunit averages were most striking
in showing the potential of the single
particle technique and proof
instrumental for gaining funding by the
National Institute of Health nonetheless
presentations of single particle
averaging results at the meeting it were
given in 1975 1709 by myself and my
collaborators martin castle and peter
zingsheim were greeted with a great deal
of skepticism one issue to be addressed
which I had already mentioned before was
the fact that due to the absence of
crystal order the average of aligned
molecule images shows no diffraction
spots in its Fourier transform in the
air for lexan inherent
measure of resolution without such
measure progress and quality cannot be
tracked and compared among different
groups following an earlier study during
my dissertation on the effects of drift
on electron micrograph I realized that
signal bandwidth is reflected by the
extent of reproducible information in
Fourier space this extent of
reproducible information is apparent
from Young's fringes that show up in the
optical diffraction pattern went to a
successive micrograph of the same
specimen field are superposed with a
slight shift applied how can this idea
be translated into computation
computational procedure reproducibility
can be quantified by dividing the data
randomly in half then comparing the
Fourier transforms of half averages over
rings in Fourier space resolution is
then defined as the ring radius we are a
measure in where measure of comparison
for instance the phase residual or R
factor or cross correlation passes a
critical threshold the same measures
computed over shells would later prove
important an estimated resolution of 3d
reconstructions as well these first
studies of image averaging immediately
brought up the problem of heterogeneity
only those mala to molecule images could
be combined in an average if they are
originated from molecules of identical
structure and showed the same you at
that time one of Aaron's from Brooklyn
students Marine Fern Hill visited my lab
with images of Limulus Polyphemus
hemocyanin which is an oligomer with the
distinct architecture producing multiple
prefer to use when negatively stained an
image in the electron microscope these
images therefore presented a perfect
example of heterogeneity
the solution to this problem came from
the inside that images once aligned with
one another may be regarded as vectors
in a space of n dimensions
n is the number of pixels groups of
images that are similar will show up as
clusters and of vectors in that high
dimensional space equivalent problems of
finding clusters in high dimensional
space were encountered in many fields of
science and gave rise to multivariate
statistical analysis a procedure which
determines a compact low dimensional
subspace tailored to the problem with
the help of jean-pierre Britta J Watts
was sent a scientist working in
Laboratory Medicine we were able to use
a program meant to sort blood samples to
sort images instead application to
hemocyanin proved the great success
early on as a set out on this new
approach to recovering structure it
became also clear to me that in order to
make systematic progress in the
development of algorithms and computer
programs with ever-changing in expanding
goals required a workbench with a large
set of tools to this end I developed a
modular image processing system called
spider which made it possible to design
complex programs from pre crowded
building blocks using a simple script
language for example the command WI
would invoke a routine for extracting a
length a portion of an image and AC
would compute the autocorrelation of an
image all programs were coded in Fortran
the most advanced language at the time
most of the initial programming was done
by a student of computer science and one
undergraduate the script language of
spider then became literally the lingua
franca in my lab and as the suit was
disseminated to other labs within a
growing community of users I attribute
the idea underlying a spider system and
it's modern and it's modular design
to my stay at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory in 1970 under the Hartness
fellowship during this one year visit I
learned the right program modules that
interfaced with Vic are the image
processing system in use by NASA since
1966 for analyzing images from planetary
missions such as the unmanned Jupiter
flyby mission now to the subject of
three-dimensional construction for
computing the three-dimensional
structure of an object from its
projections one requires the angles of
each projection to be known
determination of the angles of the
randomly oriented molecules was the most
important yet most difficult problem to
resolve the solution came from the
inside at two micrographs one of a field
of untilled particles one of the same
field he tilted contained all the
information required to assign Eulerian
angles to each tilted particle in this
geometry the angles of the tilted
particle loop projections lie on a cone
with a random azimuth giving rise later
to the term random conical
reconstruction
in 1982 I was joined by Michael
Rademacher also the student of Walter
hopper who had worked in his
dissertation on algorithms for 3d
reconstruction from projections arranged
in a regular chronicled geometry thus he
had exactly the skills needed to develop
computer programs that implemented the
random Chronicle reconstruction one
important step was still missing the
generalization of the algorithm that
assumed irregularly spaced conical
tilting to the general case of random
angles once this was accomplished by
Radha Maha in 1986 we obtained the first
single party reconstruction using the
random Chronicle method the 50s subunit
of the equal eras ohm this
reconstruction was limited in quality by
two factors one was the missing cone of
information in the three dimensional
Fourier transform a source of
unidirectional artifacts in the
three-dimensional density map and the
other way the artifact stood at the
preparation of the sample by air drying
with negative stain both were ethically
overcome at the time within a short
period the missing cone problem was
solved by merging datasets obtained with
three or more different 0 degree views
and the preparation of the sample with
negative staining was replaced by cryo
embedding in vitreous eyes following the
spectacular success of jerk du Burgess
verification method in the application
to viruses in 1984
yet another important problem affecting
the quality of all recruiter
constructions from am data is the
distortion of information by contrast
transfer function or a CTF caused by the
lens operations of the electron
microscope this problem and its effect
on the reconstructive density maps was
eventually overcome by my group and by
others through merging data obtained
with different D focus settings using a
wiener filter algorithm the first
molecules visualized by a-crying m and
reconstructed in three dimensions with a
single particle method where the e coli
ribosome hemocyanin and calcium release
channel a cranium reconstruction of the
hollow ocular Mauresmo TOA ribosome
proved to be helpful in the facing of
the first x-ray structure of the large
subunit all final reconstructions
benefit from an iterative in angular
refinement that starts out with the
first rough reconstruction in any
project dealing with a molecule whose
structures unknown it is practical to
distinguish between two phases the
bootstrap face and a refinement phase
and bootstrap phase a first rough
reconstruction is obtained either by the
random chronicle method or by an
alternative method developed by marathon
Hill and others in which common lines in
Fourier space are employed in the
refinement Phase II an existing
reconstruction is used to generate a
library of even spaced projections with
which the experimental projections are
compared to assign refined angles to
them for the next round of
reconstruction now I would like to show
a few examples for how the new
technology well before it's reached the
present state of perfection
gave us important insights into pivotal
processes of translation by the ribosome
in the late nineties one of my postdocs
rajendra arguable prepared a sample
containing allegation fact G bound to
the ribosome as it catalyzes
translocation of mRNA and tRNAs
comparison of the crying M
reconstruction with that of the unbound
ribosome showed a dramatic change the
small subunit head Road headed by almost
10 degrees this finding provided first
clues on the mechanism of Emma and a
tRNA translocation in this important
molecular machine in 2002 another
postdoc Michael voila I'm sorry in 2002
another post of Michael valor found that
in the decoding process tRNA entered the
ribosome in complex with protein in fact
the ef-tu
in a strongly distorted form in the so
called 18 state this observation
indicated that the tRNA acts as a
molecular spring apparently setting the
threshold for discrimination between
cognate and near cognate codon and
decode on pairing as a third example in
2001 we teamed up with jennifer doudna
then at yale to visualize the mRNA from
hepatitis C virus in the process of
hijacking the human ribosome my postdoc
Christian span working alongside with
Jeff chief from the Doudna team
visualized the so called iris element of
the virus attacking the small subunit of
the ribosome
even though before 2013 when the camera
the cameras came out in a crime
reconstruction fell short of resolutions
in the 3d angstrom range it was still
possible to interpret them
the basis of existing structures by
means of flexible fittings such as mdff
deriving interpretation through atomic
models I'm showing two examples among
many a six point I on strim cry a map
presenting a snapshot of the decoding
process and its interpretation by
Elizabeth Villa and the atomic model of
the ribosome from t Brucie built from
5.5 angstrom map by Yasser Hashem still
from data recorded on film I finally
come to a distinct advantage of single
particle I am that is brought out in
many applications now here unlike in
x-ray crystallography molecules are
unconstrained by crystal packing and are
able to assume the full range of
confirmations present present in
solution for a process of molecular
machine like the ribosome unless it is
stopped by a chemical intervention many
different states coexist in solution the
full potential of single particle IEM
has been realized for the introduction
of maximum-likelihood classification by
co-chairs who work as a student in the
lab of Jose Maria Caruso and later
independently the LMB MRC and Cambridge
these algorithms perform the seemingly
impossible task of disentangling changes
of view angles from changes in structure
a large well characterized ribosome data
said that we as supplied was correctly
classified in the initial study working
with his to it set multiple structures
are now routinely recovered from single
sample in the next slide
in the next slide shown I show two
examples several state of the
translation a negation cycle are fished
out from images of ribosome purified
from a cell extract of Plasmodium
falciparum the malaria parasite the
second example on the right is another
study by my group where part of the
elongation cycle is visualized in an
example containing a mutant of a
negation factor G literally where
cryo-em is now able to tell us a story
from a single sample showing how the
molecule changes its shape and binds
smaller molecules as it performs its
work ultimately even the recovery of a
continuum of structures reflecting the
states of a molecule at work and the
mapping of the free energy landscape are
no longer a distant goal even though I
have illustrated the progress achieved
by using my favorite molecule the
ribosome which now has the best
resolution of 2.5 angstrom the range of
applications in biologists is virtually
unlimited except for some lower bound on
molecule size and of course the
necessity of having the molecule
suspended in solution my own recent
collaborations with the groups with the
groups of and remarks Wayne Hendrickson
Alexander Sokolov Sookie and Philippa
Marcia demonstrate the gain and
knowledge achievable now for membrane
bound channels and receptors to conclude
this account of 40 year journey I must
confess that even though I was always a
firm believer and the technique I dreamt
up many years ago I never thought he
would see it and come to a fruition in
this spectacular way let alone that I
would earn that it would earn me a share
of the highest prize coveted by
scientists all over the world it has
been a truly fantastic journey of all
the knowledge that human medicine as a
strength the benefit from the new
technology is ultimately the best reward
I would at this point I would should at
this point you give tribute to old
people who have made this development
possible over the years it goes without
saying that without the pivotal
contributions by Mirko laureates Jack to
Boucher and Richard Henderson the field
would not have developed and prospered
in this way my things go to many
students postdocs and collaborators who
shared my vision and put it foot in so
much hard work to make it all happen but
grass uchi has been with my group for
more than 30 years in management and
support of instruments with ever
increasing complexity my very special
thanks goes to my wife Carol Saginaw who
has steadily supported me for close to
40 years and never lost faith in me in
my family and friends who have cheered
me on at every turn
what are the early developments of the
technique took place at the Watts Watson
day in Albany which provided a sheltered
supportive environment with generous
funding by the inner state of New York
particularly in the starting phase in my
expression of cattitude to the Watts
words and I would like to single out
Carmen Mandela who supported me
throughout those years as a colleague
collaborator and friend my affiliation
with the department of biomedical
science at the University of Albany
since 85 allowed me to foster academic
interactions with SUNY faculty at large
and since 2008 when I joined the faculty
of Columbia department of biomedical
sciences and biological sciences
I enjoyed multifaceted intellectual
environment foster and maintained per
one of the count country's greatest
universities my workmates been
generously supported by the National
Institute of General Medical Sciences of
NIH almost without interruption since
1981 funding for two inspiring
sabbatical states in England and Germany
was provided respectively by the four
got a foundation at the humored
Foundation I received sizeable awards
from the National Science Foundation for
several instrument purchases and support
by the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
for almost twenty years has allowed me
to build up a state-of-the-art
professionally supported cry um facility
firstly the Watts word Center and later
at Columbia University thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
could I please ask colore it's thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you